to it let's talk about the three
different forms so first of all you've
got this general form where it's just
multiplied out it's in descending order
and you've got your coefficients a B and
C in front of the variables right so the
way you would find the vertex which is
the point where the parabola bends or
turns is you would use this formula x
equals negative B over 2a so the
opposite of B over 2 times the leading
coefficient so for this example here I
would do the opposite of B which is
negative 4 over 2 times a which is 2 and
so negative 4 over 4 gives us negative 1
now if I put negative 1 back into my
equation for X I get 2 times negative 1
squared is 2 plus 4 times negative 1 is
negative 4 plus 1 that comes out to
negative 1 so the vertex here is going
to be at negative 1 negative 1 the axis
of symmetry goes right through that
x-coordinate the vertex the a value is
positive which tells us that it's
opening up like this and so that's a
quick sketch of the graph right there so
this one is in vertex form ok and you
can see the vertex is going to be at
each K and then the a is the vertical
stretch if it's positive it's going to
open up if it's negative it's going to
open down so for this one we can see
that the vertex is at positive 3
positive 1 and notice that this one is a
group of the ax has the opposite sign
the opposite effect this is actually
positive 3 if it was X plus 3 then it
would be shifting left 3 ok and then
what the a value does since it's
negative it's gonna open down and the 3
is gonna stretch it which means it's
going to be near or it's gonna go down
faster so this graphs gonna look
something like this approximately and
then the last one this is what's called
intercept form you can also think of it
as like a factored form ok it's factored
and by setting the factors these groups
equal to 0 you can solve for the
x-intercepts so if we set this to 0 we
get 2 if we set this to 0 we get 4 and
what you want to do is find the halfway
point between those two x-intercepts and
that's going to be your line of symmetry
it's also going to be the x coordinate
of your vertex so in this case that's x
equals 3 by putting 3 back into our
equation we can solve for the y
coordinate of the vertex so let's do
that 3 minus 2 is 1 3 minus 4 is
negative 1 and times 1/2 if we multiply
that all out we get y
equals negative 1/2 so this is going to
be at 3 negative 1/2 right there and you
can see there's our parabola like so so
these are the three forms that you want
to memorize and familiarize yourself for
for the SAT so let's go to some examples
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can do these on your own they give us
this equation and it says which of the
following is an equivalent form of the
equation of the graph in the XY plane
from which the intercepts can be
identified as constants in the equation
so they're telling us they want us to
put it in to intercept form that's this
form right over here this third one well
you can see this first one is in vertex
form okay that's this form right here
this one's like in the general form so
it can't be that one this one I'm not
even sure what form this is in it has to
be letter C but I would verify it by
doing a couple things you know one you
could foil this out like multiply it out
and you can see that yes it does match
this one here so all it is is this is
the factored form of this and you can
see that x-intercepts are gonna be at
negative 3 positive 1 you can find the
halfway point
that's your axis of symmetry which is
negative 1 and by putting negative 1
back in you can find the y-coordinate
and draw your parabola ok example 2 it
says the equation y equals x squared
minus 6x Plus 8 represents a parabola
which of the following displays the
vertex s constants in the equation okay
so go ahead and pause the video see if
you can do this one to give us a few
options you know and which one do you
think it would be well the first of all
this first one looks like it's in the
intercept form see how it's the factored
form so that's not it this one looks
like it's in the vertex form this one
I'm not sure what form this even
represents and this one again I'm not
sure what that even represents so it
looks like it's letter B but I would
confirm by doing a couple different
things one you could go ahead and you
could factor this you could say this is
X minus 4x minus 2 okay so what I've
done is I've written it in the intercept
form and you could graph it you can see
it's going to cross that positive 2 if
you set this to 0 and positive 4 if you
set that to 0 you find that halfway
point that's your axis of symmetry x
equals 3 and by putting it back in you
get negative 1 and positive 1 so if you
multiply those together you get negative
1 so you can see your vertex is going to
be right
here at three comma negative one like so
so your parabola is going to look like
that
so if we use the vertex form you can see
it's going to be y equals a X minus
three squared minus one right so it
looks like this is in that correct form
you can see the vertex is at three
negative one so letter B is going to be
your best answer there so go ahead and
review these three forms of the parabola
definitely something you want to know
for the SAT and if you have to review
these examples go ahead and do that as
well I'll see you in the next lesson